my scientists are warning that's a
crucial Tipping Point could be reached
in just two years time they would see
the start of the collapse of the
Atlantic Gulf Stream if Global emissions
aren't reduced on the Atlantic Meridian
Al overturning circulation known as amoc
drives the Atlantis currents by pushing
warm water from the Gulf of Mexico
northwards towards the Arctic where it
cools and sinks
when it last collapsed during the
previous Ice Age around 12 000 years ago
and could have catastrophic impacts for
Humanity sea levels would rise around
the east coast of North America and
storms would worsen in Europe while
rains in Asia Africa and South America
would be disrupted causing issues for
food production for billions of people
well Matthew England is an ocean and
climate Dynamics professor at the
University of New South Wales his
Antarctic focused work is very similar
to this latest study he's with us live
now from Sydney welcome to the program
these kind of warnings have been coming
for years haven't they
no that's right I mean this is a very
interesting study out today but it's
very true that actually our first
understanding that there could be a
bi-stable uh State there that's to say a
situation where the overturning
circulation can collapse the first
science on this was actually out in the
early 60s uh fellow by the neighbor
Henry stormall wrote a very famous paper
nowadays and it triggered a whole area
of research and we know from
paleoclimate records from basic Theory
looking at the ocean circulation there
as well as the coupled climate models we
use to project into the future we know
that this overtoning circulation is
vulnerable to change under global
warming and we have evidence that it can
switch off or collapse altogether the
time scale is a little bit uncertain but
I think all scientists would agree it's
a vulnerable system to climate change
you mentioned time scales there and is
this happening more quickly than
predicted and if so why
well it's kind of happening in keeping
with the predictions if you look at the
models we use to forecast for this
Century all of them show some sort of
slowdown of the overturning circulation
some are more rapid than others and if
we look at the evidence over the last
hundred years it's quite clear from the
records we have from paleo climate
records and direct measurements that
there's a Slowdown occurring of the
order of 10 maybe so far 15 and that
number's even discussed and debated some
people might say even higher some people
say less but
um there's definitely not an increase
and all the evidence we have is is that
there is a Slowdown underway and that's
in keeping with the projections and it
will only get worse as we change our
climate system further what kind of
action is needed then right now to avoid
a Tipping Point can this still be
averted
well it can still be averted I mean it's
important to point out that there's a
range here of of collapse points for
this circulation in this later study out
today from very soon
um right through to the end of the 21st
century so 80 or so years from now so
there's a there's an uncertainty range
to the estimate of this Tipping Point
and so if it's imminent we've already
pushed the climate system too far if
it's towards the end of this Century
then we've definitely got the time to
reduce our emissions to stop this
melting of Greenland but that's why
we've been talking about the time for
Action is now it's actually uh 20 years
past now in may on Main levels and
that's a that's a dangerous message to
mention because we don't want people
thinking it's too late it is not too
late because every single fraction of a
degree every tenth of a degree we push
the planet's temperatures up Stacks up
higher and higher odds of these
disruptive changes to our climate system
back of England thanks very much indeed
for joining us we appreciate your
insights
thank you so much